so let's say hypothetically there's a
young man here who
is dating a young woman who tends to
lean very far left
so sorry before you go any further is
she is she present right now
no she is not okay good so i can be
honest all right
all right so how might uh like do you
have any advice for how this young man
might
go about exposing her to some new ideas
without the relationship crashing
involved you're an optimist
okay
so you my friend are making a very large
mistake
i'm sure she's wonderful i'm sure she's
supremely attractive i'm sure all of
those things
it depends what the relationship is for
are you in it for marriage or like
you actually have to give me like what's
the end goal here uh yeah
marriage okay so if you're in it for
marriage then the number one thing you
must have in common with your spouse's
values
you don't have interests come after
values but most people are interested in
lots of things there are lots of
interesting things in the world
liking the same movies liking the same
art virtually worthless
what is important is that you have the
same value system so politics are a
reflection of values now there are a lot
of people
who never connect their politics with
their values so you have to determine
whether she's politically left because
this ref represents some core values or
just because she's been told a bunch of
slogans and now she repeats all these
slogans so when i first stated my wife
for example my wife thought of herself
as pro-choice and then the most
and the more that we discussed the issue
became very clear to her that she was
actually
pro-life and hadn't really considered
the issue in a serious way it was just
she was told on college campus that it
was a good thing to be pro-choice
and so she said she was pro-choice and
the same thing was true of
of gun rights for example uh she didn't
know anything about guns she'd been told
guns were bad
uh and then when i explained gun rights
to her and when it turned out that her
father was a member of the military
uh then uh then she then she shifted a
little bit politics is the tip of the
iceberg
the question is whether your your
girlfriend's politics or this
unnamed person's girlfriend's politics
uh are
are a floating bit of flotsam on the top
of the ocean or whether there's actually
a structural
underpinning for for what she's thinking
so you first have to determine that
if there is a structural underpinning
and if she really believes this stuff on
a strong level
you're really going to have to think
about whether this is something you want
to go through for the next 80 years
because it's because when it comes time
to raise your kids
i forget about you okay in my view
marriage is
marriage not relationships marriage is
about bearing and rearing children
uh ideally right my wife and i have two
children uh that is the end goal of
marriage
uh that is the telos of marriage
marriage was created so that we could
bear and raise our children and that
means that we have to have
very similar perspectives on how we want
to raise our kids now if you want to
raise your kid with traditional ideas of
virtue and decency
and she wants to raise your kids with
traditional ideas of multiculturalism
for example
then and all cultures and all opinions
being equal all behavior being equal
this is going to be a real conflict when
it comes time to parent your kids so
you so you have to ask yourself two
questions one is she movable
and two if she's not movable what is
your end goal here
because you know there's lots of fun to
be had in life but when it comes time
for marriage marriage is
as as all the married people in the room
know marriage is not the time for fun
you know marriage is when it comes when
it comes time for marriage
you know i've not totally tried i love
my wife and we have a great marriage but
see i know she's watching but it's
invite
but uh when it comes time for marriage
it is deeply important that you put
values before
all the other ancillary things if you
have values in common your marriage
cannot last anything if you don't have
values in common
then the first break and the thing's
over